القمح غذاء الشعوب والمحصول الاثمن على
مدار التاريخ موجات الجفاف وحرائق الغابات
وحتى الحروب والنزاعات السياسيه تهدد
امدادات القمح حول العالم لكن الحلق قد
ياتي من المختبر هناك حيث يعمل بحثون في
مركز جون انس في نورتش على تطوير القمح
جينيا لتعزيز قدرته على مقاومه الحراره
الشديده والجفاف الباحثون بداوا بزراعه
سلالات متنوعه من القمح جرى تخليقها جزئيا
بالاعتماد على تكنولوجيا لتحديد الجينات
داخل حقول تجارب في اسبانيا وبناء على
قدره هذه السلالات على تحمل حرارتها مناخ
شبه الجزيره الايبيريه سيحدد العلماء مدى
قدره السلالات المبتكره على حمايه
المحاصيل المستقبليه من اسوء موجات
التقلبات المناخيه وتعزيز انتاج الغذاء
للمليارات من سكان الارض